on va commencer d'abord les clichés
review eux voilà avec l'hyper u de
laetitia casta
donc vous avez non seulement appris j'ai
inventé alors d'arrêter ces cas c'est
l'hyper view la lumière change comme ça
évidemment avant on était 5 contre
contrôle maintenant on est on est plus 4
contre tout contre tout compte
alors vous avez déclaré laetitia casta
j'aime pas la télé et surtout j'aimerais
pas en faire pourquoi vous trouvez ça
frelaté la télé vous trouvez que c'est
un monde on n'est pas naturel en
télévision alors vous avez l'air très
naturel ouais mais j'essaye mais c'est
pas évident parce que il faut aller vite
parce qu'une chose à dire parfois on
vous coupe ça leur j'ai eu du mal à
imposer des gels m'a fait des
compliments sur l'a6 à vous avez
l'impression que ça claque ça très vite
que je souhaite mais oui mais nous on
est vous savez on ne fait pas marrer on
préférerait aller au bout des problèmes
en parler vraiment et tout mais voilà
les gens s'ennuient zappé c'est terrible
c'est ça qui vous énerve à la télé c'est
le zapping mais j'ai un papa qui a pu
pourquoi aussi sur la noue un copain à
papa un papa qui a pu beaucoup sur la
télécommande
exactement oui alors vous avez 20 ans on
dit que vous êtes la plus belle femme du
monde c'est pas juste pour vous flatter
pas ce que c'est
le nie toute la journée dans les
journaux et la voici fed allait voyager
un peu du monde voilà fois non mais de
la planète vous savez exactement fallait
7 mars
il ya juste une question c'est très très
personnel dans certains articles que
j'ai dit sur vous vous faites 88 60 88
et avant c'était 90 60 88 ça ne dit rien
toi c'est bien pour moi au loto mais
c'est un peu trop bien 88 60 88 ou 90 60
90 alors franchement 90 60
d'accord c'est ça le fond je suis trompé
et se centrant pour me taire son nom
s'affiche pas du tout pourquoi tu l'as
cherché celle là tu sais comment tu l'as
cherché celle là je vois ce que je veux
dire pas est-ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que on se fout des mensurations on
voit qu'elle est belle on n'a pas besoin
de savoir combien elle mesure de taille
de tour de poitrine et vous mesurer à
mazet ça je veux dire d'accord je me
suis tout à fait serein m non je t'en
prie que ça n'est pas la seule bon alors
vous dit quelque chose
votre laetitia casta donc le parler
d'eux alors oui je parle comme j'ai
envie de parler je trouve que de toute
façon les elle est très jolie qu'on n'a
pas besoin de savoir combien mesure quoi
je veux dire c'est un constat et les
belles voiles avec mes fils a trouvé un
président être un marché là non pas du
tout vous êtes sur une stèle et on vous
admire
voilà alors non un mètre soixante et
onze pour le défilé c'est embêtant c'est
pas vrai je fais pas un mètre soixante
et onze défaites qu'on met 1 m 68
les petits talons 1,68 bon vous êtes en
tous les cas pas c'est vrai enfin
monsieur monsieur plus que monsieur gros
nous en parlons tout à l'heure
surtout plus de professeurs très sérieux
très sérieux
d'ailleurs mon avis une partie
maintenant depuis tout stagne depuis le
début de tension
si le mec est un polar quand je dois
passer moi je il s'appelle flück depuis
qu'il est tout petit sans vous lui c'est
comme vous ok c'est votre vrai nom
tandis que voire dix ans il bat non moi
je dirais ça va bien donc c'est ce que
ça veut dire tiens en parlant de sa
laeticia casta ce que ça veut dire en
fait ce que ça signifie et ça lui va
très bien en plus
vous n'êtes pas latinistes pierre je
l'étais wichita casta casta ces chastes
rf issia c'est la joie se son nom
signifie joie chaste en plus c'est
merveilleux je sais et c'est vrai nom
alors été d'abord les joyeuses et elle
est chaste elle a fait ses études à les
arrêter ses études à 17 ans donc c'est
normal le latin a pas vraiment eu le
temps
j'avais même si on va jusqu'à 25 ans ont
fait pas beaucoup de la toile et non
mais on m'en avait parlé
oui c'est ça les fils yann piat
gainsbourg aussi pour alors quand l'ours
en fait nous fait elle est née en
normandie mais elle a été levée en corse
et elle adore la corse voilà c'est ça la
corse est la raison alors là vous quand
vous avez commencé dans dans le boulot
on va pas raconter toute votre carrière
parce que mais vous allez dis vous avez
refusé la chirurgie esthétique et vous
avez dit pas question qu'on touche à mes
dents ça je vous rassure tout de suite
c'est pas à vos dents qu'on a envie de
toucher tout de suite mais
c'est du rock et salsa durruty la cdu
hétéro c'est pas du tout ça alors donc
vous avez dit pas question qu'on touche
à mes dents parce que je pense que ce
serait la pire des insultes à faire à
mes parents ouais ça suffit comme ça
c'est vous qui voulez sans payer non
mais ce sont des vrais justement elles
sont vraies ce mois elles sont pas
parfaites mais ça sert à quoi l'être
parfait ça c'est difficile
non mais c'est vrai j'ai dit tous les
jours non ça sert à rien parce qu'on
semble à tout le monde après et j'ai pas
envie de ressembler à tout réussir
j'ai envie d'être moi même simplement et
d'être heureuse voilà alors votre
première photo vous étiez resté pour le
glamour italien vous avez une photo adam
et eve
au début comme sa seconde vous vous
dites la télé ça un peu fort là t il
faut aller vite faut pour faire
l'intéressant et c'est vrai mais dans le
monde de la mode si c'est terrible quand
vous avez fait votre photo on adam et
eve la première fois ça devait être
c'était pas évident parce que il y avait
un jeune homme en face de moi qui dit
adam qu'ils adorent
il était dur de la fign sûrement et
alors
et donc
c'est pas évident quand on n'a pas
l'habitude de se mettre contre un jeune
homme est parce que non mais c'est vrai
et j'avais les cheveux longs et j'avais
les cheveux entre les clichés entre
autres maux et je me souvienne demandé
de me rapprocher des j'étais comme ça
quand je rentrais levante
voilà ça c'est fait alors c'est une
jolie avant tout cas c'est une super et
et adam et eve alors bon après il ya eu
tout vu dans votre carrière ce qui était
assez drôle c'est la première fois vous
avez fait un défilé c'était pour
gauthier quand vous êtes arrivé vous à
vis des banques avec des cheveux rouges
vous avez appelé votre agent une sauce
est vraiment là je bosse en fait sortis
d'écoles et j'ai encore mon cartable
on arrive aux castes et avec mon père
m'accompagne à chaque fois et donc il
m'a dit matt en dehors je monte
j'arrive erin que comme ça mais je
retrouve des anneaux partout je vais
tenir au milieu
ouais on est décevant et donc juni mais
mince ils sont sympas nous ces gens mais
parce que c'est là où je rêve je
redescends je vois pas papa tu quoque l
agence je crois qu'on s'est trompés et
ont fait appel il non non non c'est ici
j'y retourne en fait
gauthier vous avez choisi justement
parce que vous ne ressemblez pas aux
autres en fait c'est ça l'histoire voulu
poser des questions internes voisine
avait l'habitude ces dernières années
d'avoir quand même ce qu'il a fait par
exemple que envie de faire ça dans la
vie voilà qu'est ce que je savais
comment c'est arrivé
c'est quoi le désir de départ c'est quoi
c'est arrivé par hasard un banc par
hasard c'est en vacances en corse on est
venu me voir et j'étais à l'école
j'étais petite fille s'est tournée
toujours les nuages
mon frère très très bien à l'école
toujours premier de la classe et moi je
récupérer ses professeurs le professeur
dit midi donc c'est pas normal que t'es
pas comme ton frère toi
alors j'avais un peu mal à suivre c'est
vrai est tout le temps en train amusé
dehors à faire un petit truc et on m'a
proposé de faire ce métier je savais pas
du tout ce que c'était donc le mercredi
et le week-end après l'école je commence
à faire des photos et ça m'a passionné
tête devant la caméra c'est par hervé
pavy j'ai très bien devant la devant
l'apparition tôt parce que ça me prenait
tout de suite la pause vous savez tout
très bien si notre sol ouais je m'amuse
beaucoup parce que ça me permet d'être
quelqu'un d'autre d'être par exemple une
femme que le fossat grave que je sois et
ça m'a permis de m'exprimer à ma façon
simplement donc vous aimez être
photographiés sosa d'ordonnancement
laetitia je le dis hein
laetitia n'aime pas être photographiée
quand elle ne travaille pas sur six si
vous passez un week-end avec laeticia
qui vous l'a photographiée sans arrêt
savall énervé je le dis à nos amis
c'est juste que ça m'intimide un peu
voilà parce que la branche compter le
travail a même bien de photographier
s'agit de tuer même s'il jouait
finalement tutoyer respect c'est parce
que la vente
je pense tu toi quand j'aime bien
quelqu'un je tutoie parce que je me sens
à l'aise si je me sens pas à l'aise je
vais vous voyez est autant amusé à faire
du cinéma autant amusé qu'à faire des
photos il parce que je pense que tu en
es tu mens je pense que tout le monde
rêve de faire du cinéma juste que c'est
un métier extraordinaire et ça m'a
permis d'apprendre beaucoup de choses
surtout sur moi même
oui par exemple par exemple quand on
doit dire quelque chose à quelqu'un ou
je t'aime pour vraiment le ressentir
donc à ce moment là on pense à ce qu'on
a fait avant quand on a dit je t'aime et
on ressent vraiment les choses on se
comprend un petit peu plus je trouve
c'est comme moi je pense que c'est comme
une armoire où il ya plusieurs tiroirs
on tire le repentir
en fait jacques ou sur fait ce qu'elle
dit ce qui est en train de dire là c'est
vachement bien
mais le sais pas où tu le sais pas mais
en fait ce que tu en train de dire c'est
ce que dit stacey stanislavski c'est à
dire qu'il faut servi à l'intérieur de
soi ouvrir les tiroirs l'inter de soi
pour mettre ses tiroirs au service de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas elle fait du
stress qui semble à moi la chance parce
que sur astérix edge ou falbala donc
c'est depardieu c'est ça qui est
amoureux d'elle alors que arielle
dombasle qui est sur le même film c'est
simon qui j'imagine
j'imagine bien bien sûr de questions bon
je sais que vous êtes très discrète sur
votre vie privée vous avez raison moi
aussi vous vous non on sait deux choses
en fait vous avons mieux on ces deux
choses on sait quand vous étiez petit
vous aviez des posteurs de bruel sur vos
murs est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
non d'accord non mais chez ces nano
dispose aujourd'hui non plus mais est ce
que j'ai dit non mais ce que je sais tu
es ma génération
oui et c'est quelqu'un très mignon et
chanter bien écrit et bien vous savez
quoi damian alors et la deuxième chose
là c'est encore plus surprenant parce
que bruel c'est vrai qu'à votre époque
était plein de jeunes filles des
posteurs de bruit à l'époque la pizza
pino
mais il ya quand même quand il y avait
des rêves à pizzas puis commencer à
bouffer votre arme idéale je sais pas si
c'est toujours le cas parce que sinon
alors là on est tous morts
votre mii des halles ça serait jacques
brel mais aussi les morts si on faisait
10 ha dans une interview ah bon mais ça
va
pierre bachelet qui fait moi je resterai
à personne j'ai encore beaucoup de
choses à apprendre et pour dire mon ami
des as et un peu trop c'est un peu trop
facile justement je pense que je
recherche pas l'ami des halles je tourne
à une chance
moi j'ai lu j'ai vu abandon j'ai lu que
c'est tout simplement quelqu'un de vrai
et quelqu'un qui soit lui-même et qu'il
soit sincère
bon ben voila j'ai un ami au revoir bon
c'était tout le monde en parle
rendez-vous dans quinze jours bon alors
non alors voilà dernière chose vous vous
dites pas ce que c'est on sait
finalement on se demande quand on voit
quelqu'un comme vous comment est ce que
on pourrait la séduire enfin la limite
d'âge est dépassé mais je parle pour des
gens comme laurent qui sont à la fois ça
y est ça qui est en train de marge dans
la france le roc est dans la force de
l'âge
vous vous dites comme j'aime pas les
boîtes et alors là c'est terrible parce
que vous dites je suis un peu mémère ça
veut dire aussi des discothèques
on n'aime pas les discothèques elle dit
je suis un peu mémère ça veut dire quoi
je suis jamais de seul je suis un peu
ennuyeuse vous dit c'est vous qui le
dites j'aime pas aller en boîte parce
que je trouve que j'aime bien danser oui
je trouve pas qu'on boiton prises dans
c'est vraiment oui parce que l'on se
fait marcher sur les pieds et la fumée
de cigarette on a mal aux yeux dans les
yeux gonflés comme ça moi je trouve pas
ça tellement je préfère danser chez moi
ou les boîtes déjà c'est noël ne
souhaite pas qu'on puisse rencontrer
quelqu'un s'en fout dans le noir quoi
et
bon va très bien non vous puis pour
finir vous avez dit que je suis stupide
parfois un peu bête en larges crochets
de la fausse modestie parce que le
discours que vous tenez là depuis un
moment c'est prouvé tout à fait le
contraire de ce que je pense qu'il faut
remarquer quand même et pendant un temps
tous les top models les mannequins
étaient assez fin et c'était plutôt le
look anorexiques bien sûr c'était tweedy
et 4 mo spirale d'un seul coup on a une
jeune femme devrait vrai avec des
rondeurs qui est ce que les femmes
peuvent s'identifier à elle qu'est ce
que vous voulez qu'on s'identifie à kate
moss moi je veux bien mais voilà on n'en
rencontre pas tous les jours et
renversant vraiment quand on vous a
proposé astérix vous croyez que je
croyais qu'il se passe en corse tout ce
que vous avez dit oui vous aidiez zivi
chez pas jouer et en fait ça s'est bien
passé c'est plutôt une récré pour des
conneries depardieu te sympa mais très
sympathique parce que ils n'ont pas mis
de barrière justement son panier à la
main là c'est pas joué non au contraire
ils ont ouvert les portes et ça m'a
beaucoup touché
moi j'ai envie de toi un bon esprit non
dans les signes comme ça non les gens
ont envie de passer un moment ça qu'ils
vont passer trois mois ensemble ils
veulent que ce soit grave principe oui
oui oui qui vous a fait le plus rire sim
depardieu clavier
michel galabru j'avoue que baby madaci
n'ya pas de mal gérard sais mais c'est
surtout moi ce qui m'a beaucoup touché
ses premiers jours bon après c'est le
tournage mais est ce qu'il a fait pour
jour c'était assez drôle
gérard depardieu est ce qu'il a fait il
a été lui-même est arrivé vers moi et il
est arrivé en caleçon avec des bottes le
mal
non mais moi j'aime les gens qui sont
naturels voilà quelqu'un était juste une
question comme ça vous n'êtes pas dans
le non dit x à face et que sa motivation
sera là au moins je suis pas voilà
mesdames messieurs sur un film il ya pas
pierre arditi est bien allé voir dit
allez-y précipite et obélix et astérix
contre césar merci beaucoup laetitia
donc où est passée la provoc avec
christine boutin karl zéro thierry
pfister guy konopnicki et laurent alliez
mais avant tout cette émission
maintenant on n'est plus composé
uniquement que de débat il ya aussi des
interviews qu on appelle des hyper diou
ah oui c'est un procès politique à
laquelle j'appelle donc christine boutin
bonsoir christine boutin ne soyez pas
trop vous n'êtes pas impressionné par
cet aéropage entre vous hyper view vais
essayer d'y conçoit sentent contraire
c'est que cinq contraintes dans un
langage argotique c'est la masturbation
vous saviez que dans absolument pas mais
j'aime aussi à laurent ruquier dédicaces
il va vous
alors vous êtes mariés vous avez trois
enfants vivent donc un peu en france la
personne qui défend des la famille vous
êtes fondatrice de l'alliance pour le
droit à la vie c'est ça pour les droits
de la vie les droits de la vie et vous
êtes l'idée si thierry lie à
l'association pour la promotion de la
famille
pardon l'association pour la promotion
de la famille non non j'ai pas de
l'union pour prénom c'est une
association familiale elle existe cette
association est absolument pas lié à
cette à soutien de ce type arias était
de l'association mada
vous êtes la vraie christine boutin est
ce que vous êtes bien consulteurs
pontificale sur la famille au vatican
c'est vraiment super pour un petit
figallo conseil pontifical pour la
famille oui bon quand vous dites que
vous avez de la compassion pour les
homosexuels est ce que vous trouvez pas
que finalement c'est une attitude un peu
condescendante sait comment la
compassion pour des infirmes pour des
malades ne peut être ai je dit j'avais
la compassion je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir
employé ce terme ce que je pense ce que
je sais vis-à-vis des personnes
homosexuelles et comme vis-à-vis de
toute personne quel que soit son état de
santé sa race ou sa religion j'ai de
l'amour pour toutes personnes que je
rencontre
parce que pour moi toute personne est à
l'image de dieu je peux poser une
question parce que c'est vrai je vous ai
déjà reçu sur inter cette semaine et
mais une question que je ne vous ai pas
posé on avait on a tous remarqué que
vous ne dites jamais les homosexuels
mais les personnes homosexuelles
pourquoi qu'il ya différents c'est parce
que les personnes de petite taille les
personnes de couleur
parce que avant tout pour moi la dignité
bien à la personne et non pas en
fonction de son comportement son choix
politiques ou de sarasota religion c'est
d'abord une personne et par le fait que
j'indique personnes homosexuelles et
bien c'est pour moi un vrai respect un
homosexuel c'est pas votre non pas du
tout une situation respect c'est un et
incités à sauter leur voiture
conscients qu'ils parlent j'en sais rien
comme j'ai mon subconscient qui parle
comme le vôtre oui l'homosexualité
tensions qui peuvent comme le vôtre il
parle à tout le moins ces critères
rentrent de plus en plus dans la vie
courante aujourd'hui à peu près sur dix
films qui sortent au cinéma en ce moment
une a5 qui sont comme sacré
l'homosexualité 5 qui sont consacrés à
l'homosexualité féminine
la plupart des gens maintenant qu'ils
sont homosexuels le disent beaucoup de
gens par exemple c'est très bien je vous
montre un petit bout de clips la judge
michael qui est un chanteur bien connu
il a été attrapé dans les toilettes
hollywood et non pas voir ça c'est très
sexy
alors ce que je veux dire en montrant ça
c'est que finalement maintenant voilà
quoi avant on se souvient dans le temps
quand les chanteurs étaient homosexuels
ne disait pas c'était secret ça se
raconte et maintenant voilà et on la
trappe dans les toilettes et il fait un
clip pour dire oui je suis homosexuel
donc est ce que vous pensez pas par
rapport à ça que finalement c'est
quelque chose qui est passé dans les
moeurs qu'on n'y peut pas grand chose
finalement que je ne crois pas que ce
soit complètement passées dans les
moeurs je pense que il y a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour que ça
passe dans les moeurs
du reste vous donner l'exemple d'un
chanteur mais moi j'entends dans le
monde politique
beaucoup des personnes de la communauté
homosexuelle reproche que les hommes
politiques vous paraît-il il ya beaucoup
d'homosexuels paraît-il il y en a très
peu qui affirment qu'ils osent affirmer
et regardez par exemple monsieur
labarrère
cela dit depuis fort longtemps et tout à
fait respectable et amira watanabe
également à 7 me pose personnellement
aucun problème dans ce qu'il faut dire
c'est quand même qu'il ya très peu de
gens en tout cas en france qui le disent
qu'ils l'ont dit et on peut le
comprendre on n'a pas les blâmer je
trouve ça ferait d'ailleurs qu'on fasse
ce qu'on appelle je crois de de la
outings ses fonctions dénonçant généraux
c'est un choix c'est à chacun de dire ce
qu'il a envie de le dire mais il faut
surtout préciser que c'est beaucoup plus
facile à dire quand on est un peu connus
ou célèbres comme la george michael est
évidemment que cette partie de la bonne
bourgeoisie bordelaise
son entourage ne permettrait
probablement pas que la personne n'y a
pas super la branche principale de mon
discours ne laisse que parce que les
normes et dans les milieux
dans les milieux populaires ce n'est pas
non plus une chose que l'andi fascinant
évident ce tirage mais on disait que
j'ai dit c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué pour quelqu'un qui est
tourneur dans une usine d'exprimer sa
célèbre en face à son entourage que par
rapport à un chanteur à succès qui toute
façon sera protégé par sa notoriété
je vais vous dire quand même quand vous
grandissez la bible quand vous
grandissez la bible la bible ce
infernale comme la bible c'est des
sodomites il ya beaucoup ilyasova mégots
mort il ya de l'inceste
quand la fille aînée de lot torche son
père pour qu'il la saute c'est dans
l'ariège la génèse 19 génèse mais bien
passer sa flotte je préfère le prince
d'égypte moi je n'aime pas mais ça vous
le savez tout ça absolument pas n'en
suis pas là considéré que vous avez la
fille de lot à fille aînée de lot fait
boire son père et son père lui c'est un
enfant et après ça recommence avec la
soeur cadette salomon polygamie 1000
femmes
les maris marié à 12 ans dans ce que je
veux dire c'est que financier des
comportements humains qui sont rapportés
dans la bible mais en ce qui concerne la
bim
je peux malheureusement moi je n'ai pas
préparé comme vous et je ne peux pas
vous donner la bbc mais bon c'est mon
sac et dans la loge messieurs
mais je suis désolé mais on publie me
chercher on verra que la bible et dans
mon sol qu'à ce moment là je voudrais la
référence exacte
c'est à la fois dans l'ancien de
nouveaux états membres effectifs m'en
dit très clairement que l'homosexualité
n'est pas acceptable
oui enfin 16 la polygamie tout ça c'est
la fin de toute façon le problème n'est
pas celui là vous m'aviez posé la
question de savoir pourquoi j'avais
montré cette bible et bien j'avais mangé
montrer cette ville parce que c'est l
ouvrage que j'avais dans mon sac
madame guigou pour gagner du temps nous
lisez pour une deuxième fois le discours
qu'elle nous avait une heure plus tôt
donc moi j'ai essayé de lui donner
d'autres sujets de lecture et on n'en a
pas voulu
mais par contre monsieur h députés
communistes à lui et à lui la bible
cantique des cantiques et l'ecclesia ça
choque personne contre la menace était
communiste tout le monde trouve ça
normal
voilà les premières est la fête de
l'humanité la prochaine fois vous savez
quel thème mêlera jésus on trouve ça
tout à fait normal
personne ne dit rien mais si vous tendez
quelque chose parce qu'elle était
catholique parce qu'elle est catholique
pardonnez moi et bien à ce moment là ça
devient objet de scandale
c'est absolument c'est une fête staline
avec de vigne mais moi je tue pas
stalinienne alors moi je me demande au
fond je vais vous dire pourquoi vous ai
demandé d'être là ce soir parce qu'on a
parlé de du consensus on a parlé du
politiquement correct on va parler la
provocation se demandant où est passée
la provocation
moi je me demande au fond si vous n'êtes
pas la dernière provocatrice parce que
finalement aujourd'hui tout le monde
pense à peu près la même chose et vous
vous arrivez à l'assemblée nationale
vous prenez la parole vous ai alors dit
encore plus provocatrice que ça le
booste vous connaissez ce journal ça que
je viens vous vous avez donné vous et
comme la provocation ça dans un journal
s'appelle tabloïds qui est un journal
gay
delà de la région avaient vous thierry
maintenant je reçois battant je suis
abonné à temps ceddat région rhône alpes
c'est le journal gai de la région de la
région rhône alpes il ya un article qui
est en page 6 jeudi sa patricia voilà
qui s'appelle christine boutin j'aime le
sexe mois jura contre ça moi aussi
j'adore le sexe non mais voilà je montre
à la caméra
donc je sais pas est ce que vous vous
êtes une provocatrice tu sais par quoi
non mais c'est le jeu façon vos paroles
vous en bien j'ai les miennes orgasme et
m'engage également
et quand j'ai accepté de faire 2 1 une
interview dans cette revue gay je les
fais parce que je n'ai pas de raison de
ne pas répondre à une demande d'une
revue gay pour préparer le pacs j'ai
rencontré la communauté homosexuelle
ce que j'ai dit c'est pas simplement
dans mon idée de l'idée au rejet de
l'idéologie de dogmatisme
j'essaie d'être compétent des personnes
homosexuelles me demande une interview
je réponds alors ce que j'ai essayé de
leur faire comprendre c'est que j'aime
et l'amour j'assure et donc ça a été
titré j'aime le sexe est bien trop mais
c'est pas mal non n'était pas
contradictoire
merci ben voilà donc maintenant on va
passer ses invités à dîner madame boutin
sur l'antenne d'inter puisque je suis
offert un bouquet de fleurs c'était toi
là je me suis dit comme ça va se passer
elle va elle va sûrement pleurer pendant
la mission
et là c'était de la passion c'était des
larmes cd des larmes de crocodile j'ai
été profondément blessée est vrai
absolument je chez steam que le premier
ministre est la question que je voulais
vous poser en décembre a du mal à vous
croire que ça vous c'est votre
responsabilité
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai
été blessé et je voulais demander au
premier ministre si véritablement
c'était sa façon de traiter les femmes
ce qu'il venait de faire devant
l'ensemble de la classe politique - vous
avez vous savez bien que donc bon
annoncer très bien vous aviez tout ce
que j'espère être un des premiers c'est
un nom même si c'est mal connaître une
stabilité à vous vous savez très bien
que
quand même le premier à avoir commencé à
faire rentrer les femmes laval et enfin
sur dix on est d'ailleurs tout de suite
ce n'est pas je suis pas beewi on est
très en deçà de ce qu'il faudrait c'est
d'amour d'efforts mais je suis
absolument sous jospin de 2000 par
ailleurs encore beaucoup des fouets la
parité va pas dire tout est justement
que j'allais me paraît utile quand on
voit commerce est une femme debbie merci
à tous les à côtés des questions on va
avancer je suis désolé donc on passe au
débat donc on appelle toc chaude il
quelque chose encore caravan voici
encore une chose je sais pas vous dites
que le premier ministre est une curieuse
idée de la manière dont on traite un
député moi il me semble en tout cas
qu'un certain nombre de vos collègues
députés ont une curieuse manière de
traiter les femmes dans l'hémicycle et
ça malheureusement ça se voit très
souvent la télévision
je suis bien placé jeudi onze collègues
c'est mon collègue objet d'un mois
monnaies collègues de l'autre
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
femmes disent je dis qu'il est très
agréable est une femme en politique
parce que nous sommes sont pour toi
alors on va passer au troisième débat de
la soirée les anges existe film est
d'abord on va faire pierre arditi unies
pnue
bah oui bah ouais c'est vrai que ça vous
tombe dessus un moment là avec chez moi
à faire une hyper view que ça va donner
vous donner en plus l'occasion de
répondre à un certain nombre de papiers
que j'ai vu sur vous dernièrement et qui
n'étaient pas tous très sympathiques en
tous les cas
donc on va vous pouvez poser des
questions aussi à pierre arditi petit
pas sur ce les mêmes que moi mais sur
des sujets plus progressives ou
l'éducation plus intéressante qu'elle
est plus intéressante que moi ça sera
difficile
alors il y avait un article dans libé
c'était lundi dernier loris 11 qui
disait pierre arditi talent caché caché
chu teh il parlait de vous en disant
vous faites partie des acteurs qui
pompent les gros le gros des cachets de
la fiction à la télé et il parlait de
stars vieillissantes
oui bon c'est que comme on a presque le
même âge je trouve ça ignoble je tiens à
le dire
d'abord il faudrait il faudra expliquer
à la personne qui a écrit ça dont je ne
sais pas de nom puisque c'est maintenant
c'est juste des initiatives et que
paris-nice ya plus tard c'est exagéré
oui je vous dois mon moulin parce que
c'est très exactement ce qu'ils veulent
et d'y aller ou la sega vous d'abord
faudrait déjà cessé d'employer ce mot à
tord et à travers pas ce qui ne signifie
plus rien une star c'est quelque chose
de très particulier il ya extrêmement
peu je n'en fais pas partie
alors c'est pas du tout de la fausse
modestie chez moi je ne suis absolument
pas une star ensuite bon je ne vois pas
trop l'intérêt de 2,2 me regarder de
cette manière là d'abord bien évidemment
je ne pompe pas à moi tout seul
l'ensemble de l'argent de la fiction je
vois que sur certains certaines chaînes
ils en font tellement peu qu'après tout
on peut penser que jean pompe une bonne
partie de cette sortie de pas citer de
noms voilà non mais je veux dire par là
que je n'ai rien à dire sur le fait
qu'on puisse critiquer en l'occurrence
une série de télévision qui
s'appellerait un font six que j'ai
tourné que brigitte fossey vanek du prr
certain nombre d'autres je comprends
très bien qu'on n'aime pas ça on a tout
à fait le droit de dire ça me choque
absolument pas je n'ai aucun rien à dire
là dessus je ne vois pas l'intérêt de me
et de me taper la gueule de cette
manière là d'abord parce que tout ça est
évidemment totalement faux je ne
fonctionne pas plus qu'un certain nombre
d'autres gens qui travaillent dans la
finance et même chaîne ensuite mon dieu
je suis j'ai toujours dit je crois que
je monte je suis un acteur
pluridisciplinaire et je fais du théâtre
du cinéma de la télévision quelquefois
même jeudi les textes que je mon honneur
à moi c'est de passer dans l'arène et a
fait deux roues de beckett à guitry que
je considère que mon métier c'est ça que
j'ai été baigné dans ce bain là puisque
nous avons à peu près le même âge et que
nous avons été biberonné à robert
richard selby brenets robert hirsch j'ai
été biberonné à jouvet j'ai été
biberonné à brasseur je ne me compare
pas à eux mais autant que je m'en
souvienne ces gens là faisait aussi un
peu ça c'est à dire que brasseur disait
lui-même
je vais m'amuser dans la journée je veux
faire mon métier de ses rêves tout à
fait bon donc je vois pas en quoi cette
chose sera une tare ensuite que ce soit
vieillissant naturellement je suis
vieillissant je trouve que finalement je
veux ni plutôt pas trop mal on trie plus
tôt mieux c'est quand bercy cian 5s
qu'est ce que vous pensez que pierre
arditi vit bien franchement oui je
consomme un homme est plus beau quand tu
as passé dix ans mais les filles
maintenant j'ai beaucoup plus beau quand
continuer parce qu'il devient plus
mature et voilà c'est vrai c'est pas on
ne sait pas mais voilà tout ça tout ça
simplement pour dire tout ça pour dire
eh bien cette grotte tout ça tout ça
pour dire que ça m'a profondément déplu
non pas qu'on n'aime pas cette série ça
je m'en contre un tape complètement mais
que cette manière de me regarder
je la trouve infâme et finalement comme
dirait l'autre il ya des lettres qui
vaut mieux recevoir plutôt que de les
avoir écrites et déshonorent leurs
auteurs la 16e minute ça vous emmerde
rémois oui je relèverai mais bien sûr
vous avez raison ça me ça me blesse
parce qu'une certaine manière c'est un
journal que j'aime bien et c'est un
journal que je lis pratiquement tous les
jours mais ma lecture de libération
s'arrête au paj politique économique
fait je ne lis plus les pages
culturelles de libération qui sont j'ai
le regret de le dire des pages
totalement incomplète pour le moins qui
encensent une toute petite partie de ce
qui se passe culturellement dans notre
pays et en conséquence de quoi je trouve
que les pages culturelles de libération
ne font pas leur boulot non pas parce
qu'elle ne m'attaque mois mais encore
une fois ça me blesse puisque j'aime
bien ce journal je veux dire que cette
manière de regarder me fait un peu
penser à une presse d'occupation qui
tout d'un coup deviendrait racisme alors
je n'ai pas envie qu'on deviendra site
avec moi je crois n'avoir rien fait dans
ma vie qui mérite ce traitement la très
bien non mais ce qu'on pourrait se dire
est ce que le fait d vous avez cinq
contre trois ans donc est ce que le fait
54 est-ce que je suis plus jeune que
vous alors est ce que la question avant
de passer à rêver peut-être vous préparé
une série pour france 2 qui s'appelle
les 80 unarc qui est donc qui parle des
gens de gauche qui ont perdu leur âme
après 80 parle d'une de tout de tout un
groupe de gens qui traversent cette
période au moment où la gauche arrive au
pouvoir ils sont pas forcément de gauche
je n'ai pas ce sentiment a perdu votre
âme vous non je n'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir perdu mon âme et je n'ai pas
l'impression que tous les gens de gauche
est forcément perdu leur âme même si à
certains moments ils se sont un peu
perdus
très bien alors on en arrive à rêver
peut-être donc est la pièce que de jean
claude grumberg que vous jouez au
théâtre du rond point des champs elysées
avec michel aumont marcel maréchal et
chantal neuwirth mise en scène de jean
michel ribes or ce que je veux dire
parce que je suis pas critique de cinéma
eric est donc là au québec de théâtre et
qui est non plus c'est vrai qu'on est
allé voir cette pièce et que rio main
dans la main dans la main puisque
maintenant comme vous le savez un
ensemble on attaque cédant que non mais
sérieusement on sait je veux dire c'est
une pièce grave mais le texte est
tellement drôlement écrit avec certaines
fois d'ailleurs grunberg le deed un côté
un peu almanach vermot un essai
tellement mis en scène une façon joyeuse
par ribes que finalement un thème aussi
grave
quelqu'un qui veut venger son père dont
le père a disparu pendant la guerre qui
veulent venger enfin j'en parle mal
parce que dit nous c'est un rêve en fait
ce qui est formidable c'est que c'est
comme un rêve c'est comme un rêve comme
un rêve
oui mais c'est au fond la pièce elle
elles disent que ce que grumberg a assez
souvent dit il est obsédé par l'image de
ce père déporté qu'il ne connaît pas et
au fond à l'intérieur de ce dans
l'atelier le levain thématique est très
classique et très terrienne on attend
quelqu'un ne doit revenir à revenir ici
on voit apparaître une sorte de spectre
qui est un spectacle qui est à la fois
le spectre dan nate mais qui est aussi
le spectre de ce père perdu simplement
les dans le domaine du rêve et on est
dans le domaine de la nuit n'est là le
combat de la nuit l'a emporté sur le
combat du jour et la nuit
tout est possible tout est permis mais
plus rien ne sera impuni oui c'est ça en
fait la thématique de la pièce ça me au
milieu d'un d'un magma qu'est celui d'un
rêve globale qui comme dans tous les
rêves semblent n'avoir ni queue ni tête
et quand même petite amie qui vient
donner ça prend une cohérence ib sens
finira par par emmené par emmener tout
comme est en réalité d'ailleurs cet
enfant homme vers sa douleur initial qui
est celle de la perte de ce pays un
enfant ce matin chantal neuwirth au
début c'est ça c'est son épouse après
c'est sa mère sa femme ses traits on
dirait je sais pas si c'est une bonne
façon d'envoyer les gens voir la pièce
mais ça fait penser à un bon trip
d'acide quoi c'est bien bien dribbler
santé
j'ai tous les baby boomer comprendront
ce que je veux dire
[Musique]